er hat keine ahnung dem er hier folgt
durch diesen so realen raum verführt von
einer geheimnisvollen schönheit
er läuft ihr einfach hinterher
wie hypnotisiert folgt ihr in einen
schwarzen see aus dicker flüssigkeit in
dem nur er untergeht sie nicht
vielleicht spricht diese szene für unser
eigenes gefühl in diesen ganzen film
wir folgen der anziehungskraft der
geschichte in die nacht
worum genau geht es diese frage bleibt
in dem film anderes kind von johnson
glazer oft im dunkeln wird erst in der
letzten sekunde beantwortet hollywood
star scarlett johansson spielt diese
namenlose frau unter der schwarzen
perücke ist sie kaum zu erkennen sie ist
nicht von dieser welt sie ist ein alien
mit einem klaren auftrag
sie soll menschen fleisch für ihr volk
draußen im universum besorgen also
verführt sie junge männer in den straßen
von glasgow
sie ist ein serienkiller scarlett
johansson gelingt ihre verwandlung in
dem film unglaublich gut
sie spricht kaum und wenn dann klingt es
als ahnte sie nur vage was eine
unterhaltung ist
sie schaut mit fremden augen auf die
welt und die schaut sehr fremd zurückkam
so spielt sie ein amorphes wesen in
menschenhaut
die sie trägt wie ein maßgeschneidertes
kleidungsstücke
dennoch nie ganz passt regisseur glazer
hat schon einige filme aber vor allem
viele musikvideos gedreht das format
nimmt er hierauf er verknappt
informationen eher fragmentiert
zusammenhänge und kombiniert das mit der
realen welt durch versteckte kameras
wenn scarlett johansson durch die
shopping mall läuft und sich einen
lippenstift kauft wenn sie männer
anspricht und in ihren bann lockt dann
wissen die menschen um sie herum nicht
wer sie ist und dass ein film gedreht
wird erst hinterher werden sie darüber
aufgeklärt dass gläser interessiert und
fasziniert sind effekte wie verändern
sich wahrnehmung und verhalten der film
andere skin wird am ende nicht alle
rätsel lösen
die er uns unterwegs gestellt hat wir
spekulieren oft wir ahnen nur aber wir
können ohne zweifel sagen es ist einer
der exzentrischsten unheimlichsten und
rätselhaftesten filme seit langem
er zeigt was kino kann nämlich
überraschen
er lässt uns nicht los geht's einfach
unter die haut